it's good to see everyone here again and
we're going to pick up where we left off
on on our last you know look at
spiritual formation I encourage you as
you're able to to take notes this is
something that is it's sweeping the
Christian world right now and few people
realize the roots of this movement where
it came from I know once we get through
this and we start in on our next part of
the presentation you're gonna be really
startled because we're gonna bring it
home to now to modern day so let's open
with the word of Prayer Father in Heaven
our lives are in your hands and father
we thank you that when you are in charge
everything falls exactly where it's
supposed to father teach us each day to
trust in you keep us in perfect peace
because our minds are stayed and
anchored in thee send your holy angels
Lord Jesus Christ surround protect and
strengthen us reveal your power and your
love in our lives in Jesus name we ask
believing and we thank you because you
cannot lie
amen so we ended our last session
talking about dr. Kellogg's wife Ella
Eaton and her greatest spiritual
influence was the director and president
of the university Alford Center his name
was dr. Abram H Lewis and Ella
introduced this man because she held him
in such high regard to dr. Kellogg she
was she was anxious for the two of them
to meet because Kellogg was a brew
you know physician and this man was you
and her eyes a very brilliant man of God
dr. Lewis who lived from 1836 to 1908
was an accomplished speaker he was also
known as the voice of the seventh a
Baptist Church and the author of the
denominations leading periodical called
the Sabbath recorder and when I was
putting this presentation together I
went online that paper is still being
produced today but back then I don't
think it's that way now but back then it
was known that the Sabbath recorder was
steeped in pantheism and the doctor of
pantheism pantheism is the belief that
God is in all things some believe he's
only in living things like new fruits of
vegetables and animals and humans but
others go even farther and they say that
God or deity is actually in everything
whether it's alive or not alive it makes
no difference according to Lewis he had
experienced his own shaking of faith
while he was yet seventeen years of age
while he was yet only 17 years of age
when under the influence of a brilliant
skeptic and physician and through the
right rationalism I'm sorry let me start
that again and through the rationalism
of this dangerous span the young Lewis
reported that he nearly lost all faith
in the Bible and Orthodox Christianity
so Lewis's own writings he said this is
what happened to him at 17 years of age
he was introduced to this physician and
because of this physicians influence
Lewis almost gave up God he actually had
written to the seventh day Baptist
denomination and
ask them to remove his name from their
books because he said I can't even
profess to believe in God anymore and
there was a pastor in the church who saw
you know God did not want to give up on
Lois even though Lois was about to give
up on him and he refused to remove his
name from the books
dr. Lewis and his wife Melissa visited
and joined the Battle Creek Sanitarium
after hearing of the success of its many
patients in regaining their health and
in 1895 the Lu Lewis and his wife
Melissa became honored guests at the
Kellogg home
I don't know how extensive the stay was
if he was only there you know for a few
weeks or if they stayed for a prolonged
visit but they regularly began visiting
and and spending time together Kellogg
greatly admired Lewis and it is said
that over the next two years he received
and read every issue of Lewis's
publication the Sabbath work order now
remember that publication was steeped in
pantheism but it was worded in such a
way that you couldn't put your finger on
it
and there's a reason why Ellen White
even said she said we have got to be
very careful when we're talking about
pantheism she said because and I had to
learn this there were many things I was
doing where I was I would wind up
quoting all of these pantheists and then
I would sit back and I would realize
I've gotta go get on my knees and pray
because as I was quoting these people
when I was writing the influence that
had influenced them began to try to
influence my thoughts and I would have
to step back and say go open God's Word
and claim the blood of Christ so even in
these presentations and these messages
I'm trying to be very careful on what we
quote
although dr. Kellogg had been
entertaining the potential of these
pantheistic theories as new light since
before James White death in 1881 it was
not until the pre-conference talks held
at the ministerial Institute in Lincoln
Nebraska in 1897 that he made these
views public at this conference at the
pre-conference talks he and some of the
other men were having discussions and he
began to publicly come out in the open
with what he believed and unfortunately
because of arrogance and pride that had
somehow found its way into his life he
was unwilling to yield even when sister
white and other men and women of God had
warned him that the path he was on was
dangerous his first presentation that
was given at that conference was given
on February 16th and it was titled God
in nature in which he drew heavily upon
the statements from the pen of Ellen
White taking them out of context in
order to lay a foundation for the
messages that followed there's places
where Ellen White will talk about how
God's power can be seen in every created
thing that the law of God his character
can be revealed in every created thing
but it doesn't say that God was in every
living thing so Kellogg under the
influence of the enemy began to see
these statements in a false light and he
quoted extensively from her in that
first presentation Kellogg second
message was titled God in man and it was
here that the first hints of an iceberg
were revealed
this is a quote from Kellogg gravitation
acts instantaneously throughout all
space by this mysterious force of
gravitation the whole universe is held
together in a bond of unity we have here
the evidence of a universal presence an
intelligent presence an all-wise
presence and an all-powerful presence
he's talking about gravitation you jump
off the house you fall he said there's a
presence there within this law of
gravity a presence by the aid of which
every atom of the universe is kept in
touch with every other atom this force
that holds all things together and that
is everywhere present thrills throughout
the whole universe and acts
instantaneously
throughout boundless space this
intelligence can be nothing else than
God himself and then Kellogg went on to
say what a wonderful thought that this
same God is in us and in everything
William Spicer he was a missionary did
not even know he had any involvement in
this and I bought one of his books
recently and great missionary stories he
was serving as a missionary in southern
Asia and he was the editor of our
publication called the oriental Watchmen
he had been well acquainted with the
Hindu teachings of pantheism through his
work as a missionary there in Asia a lot
of people don't realize this but when I
was in the martial arts I began in the
Chinese art of kung fu
and in my mind growing up in those arts
at you from the age fourteen onward I
had in my mind that you know the Grand
Master's it's all about China and the
last Grand Master I trained under I
remember the first time that I went to
visit him at his home he had a training
facility there at his home and I
remember after we finished training he
asked me to come in if I wanted to get
something to eat
and we went into his home and on almost
every wall in that home there were these
huge tapestries and I expected to see
Chinese everything because this man was
a Grand Master in shaolin kung fu when I
got inside there every one of the
tapestries were of Hindu gods and it was
like I remember going home that day
thanking Shaolin kung-fu Hinduism why
does he have these Hindu gods on all the
walls of his house if he's a Shaolin
Grandmaster at that point I still had
not done enough research to know that
everything in China came from India
India is where Hinduism spread out when
it went to China they had to modify
Hinduism because the Chinese people
their culture was different so it's like
Christianity but you've got all these
different denominations that's what
happened to Hinduism Hinduism became
Buddhism in China and they called it
Chan Buddhism in Japan they called the
same art Zen Buddhism but all of its
roots go back to the Hindu god of India
the Hindu religion but says he had
become well acquainted with the Hindu
teachings of pantheism however upon
returning to Battle Creek in 1901 he was
shocked to discover that the same
religious principles and errors that
were now being espoused and advocated by
dr. Kellogg and his followers he was
hearing Kellogg and some of the men that
had fallen under Kellogg's
influence and he was thinking I just got
back from India this is the same thing
their religion is saying writing of a
conversation which he and dr. Kellogg
held after his return to America Spicer
writes and this is a quote by any
understanding I had of language I was
listening to the ideas of the
pantheistic philosophy that I had met
with in India in fact I was told by
Kellogg that pure pantheism as the early
teachers conceived it was indeed right
that God was in the things of nature a
personality was in every blade of grass
and every plant it's important to make a
note of this I don't have this quote on
screen but sister white made a statement
she said we are not to concern ourselves
with identifying or understanding the
presence and personality of God
she said silence is eloquence it means
we know God has a form because we were
made in His image we know he was in
heaven his son his only begotten son was
in the water in Jordan and when Christ
came up out of the water and the heavens
were opened and God spoke and said this
is my beloved Son in whom I am well
pleased God sent his spirit upon his son
in the form of a dove we have never been
told that we need to comprehend or
understand that Ellen White said it's a
matter of faith right now within our own
church and I'm not even going to get
into this but there's a huge conflict
going on over the personality and the
presence of God let me tell you
something and I didn't have any
intention even bringing this up every
seventh-day Sabbath keeping Christian in
the world is going to have conflict soon
the entire world is going to come
against us we don't need to be divided
over things that God said are not
essential for our salvation and that
means and I've got friends that are all
one side and I've got friends that are
on the other and unlike guys
this person is addicted to drugs this
person's addicted to pornography this
person's got a father that beat him when
they were a child
this person was abused by their uncle
when they were a child this person is
about to go through a divorce why don't
we focus on setting the captives free
why don't we put our focus on the things
that matter the most we just read that
quote from Kellogg and what elder Spicer
said now listen to this quote this is a
Hindu guru he says each soul is
potentially divine and I'm going to be
careful because we know the Bible says
in 2nd Peter 1:4 that by God's promises
we are made partakers of what the divine
nature remember that word I told you
make a note of that that's important
that word nature nature doesn't mean
just character it's not the same word
character and nature nature can include
parts of character but they're not the
same you could have two dogs brother and
sister or two brothers they were born
from the same mother dog one of them
lives over here across the road they
have to keep them caged up he's mean and
vicious and angry and ugly this one over
here would go home with the mailman if
you let him they both have canine nature
but they have two different characters
do you understand nature and character
are not the same thing I want to throw
this in because this is something we're
going to talk about at the end the Bible
says God
loan has immortality right what does
immortality mean you can't die
you can't die the word god in greek is
Theos that that's the greek word in
Strong's Concordance do you know what
the definition is it has two definitions
only two deity and divinity the hundred
and forty-four thousand they won't die
will they will they do you know why
because they have been made partakers of
the divine nature through faith and
obedience death has no dominion over
them they perfectly reflect the
character of Christ and they have been
made by faith partakers of his very
nature not just his character he says
each soul is potentially divine you see
how two paths running side by side she
said you can hardly distinguish the the
truth from the error until you get to
the end because the farther you go down
the path it starts one inch off here but
a hundred yards out it's 25 feet off do
you understand the goal is to manifest
this divinity within inwardly by
controlling nature nature external
nature that means your flesh and
internal nature do this either by work
or worship or psychic control or
philosophy by one or more or all of
these and be free this is the whole of
religion that's what the Hindus say
now let me show you the same Hindu
teaching in a modern context how many
people here have ever heard of the movie
the film series Star Wars Disney just
bought all the rights you know two years
ago I think three years ago George Lucas
those those movies have done more to
affect people for unrighteousness than
probably any other thing that's ever
been put out because originally he said
they were supposed to be children's
movies but now it's like there's a whole
generation since nineteen seventy
something when the first film came out
that they're enthralled by the story
this is a labbett Episode five listen to
what is said here by this little green
creature who sort of looks like a demon
to his apprentice he says my Ally is the
force life breeds it makes it grow its
energy surrounds us and binds us
luminous beings we are not this crude
matter and then he tells Luke you must
feel the force around you Luke between
you and me the tree the ship the rock he
was saying the exact same thing and when
you when you watch some of the other
series that we've done on this we quote
Lucas Lucas caught every bit of this
from Hinduism and Buddhism
he said this is what I was trying to
teach the first printing of Kellogg's
living temple was in 1903 and of this
danger God's people had been warned
Ellen White says there is a class of
literature more defiling than leprosy
and more deadly than the plagues of
Egypt against which our publishing
houses need unceasingly to guard in
accepting commercial work
let them beware lest matters presenting
the very science of Satan be admitted
into our institutions let not work
setting forth the soul-destroying
theories of hypnotism spiritualism
Romanism or other mysteries of iniquity
find a place in our publishing houses
now I'm going to I'm going to introduce
something here up just a thought
it says hypnotism most people think of
hypnotism of you know I'm dangling some
trinket on a chain and I get you to fall
into a sleep or I flash a light or or
something in order to take over your
conscious mind the first case of
hypnotism Ellen White says happened in
Eden and she said Satan sought to
exercise that same power over our Savior
in the wilderness when he was tempting
him and when I when I read that I
thought my first thought I hate to say
it was ignorance I thought how in the
world did the devil think for a moment
he was going to hypnotize Christ I mean
really and then the Lord spoke to me and
he was like Eric don't forget about NLP
and we're not going to do a session on
that but NLP it's neuro linguistic
programming I heard about that 20 years
ago people were really warning people in
our church as well as other churches
this is coming in I didn't realize that
almost every college and university in
America secular colleges you go online
and find out almost every one of them
offer courses in NLP do you know why
because they're teaching corporate
America to use NLP to influence all the
workers in their corporation and then
they're whatever their business is
they're teaching past
how to do it to influence their
congregations their teaching professors
how to use it so that they can influence
a hundred and fifty students in a class
without having to dangle something NLP
works because you get the other person
into dialogue and conversation and then
you take what they're responding with
and you turn it just a little bit and
then you you lead them to say things
that they never had any intention of
saying you enter into their mind for
that reason Ellen White said Christ
would not enter into conversation with
Satan when Satan came to tempt him she
said he knew he's trying to use that
same power on me that he did on Adam and
Eve so he would not enter into
conversation do you know what he did
thus saith the Lord it is written period
not written in a book I'm not saying
that the book doesn't matter but where
does the Bible say God's Word supposed
to be written and that promise he has
given us I will write my law in your
hearts and in your minds not with ink
not on tables of stone but in the
fleshly tables of your heart 2nd
Corinthians 3 verse 3 a lot of times we
look at God's law we say it was written
on tables of stone because it will stand
forever it didn't stand for 40 days have
you ever thought about that
God wrote it with his own finger on
tables of stone how long did it last
before it was broken forty days Moses
came down they were already in apostasy
and he broke him and God was like bring
them back up you know I've come back up
here I'll write them again Zechariah
chapter I think it's chapter seven
actually says why God wrote
stone he said because you had made your
hearts like an adamant stone that's why
Ezekiel 36 says I'm gonna have to take
out your heart of stone and give you a
heart of flesh and then I will write my
law on a heart that is surrendered and
loves me that's what changes you today
they are coming in to educational
institutions and into the churches
everywhere spiritualistic teachings that
undermine faith in God and in his word
the theory that God is an essence or an
energy pervading all nature is received
by many who profess to believe the
Scriptures these beautiful
representations are similar to the
temptation that the enemy brought to
Adam and Eve in Eden but however
beautifully clothed this theory is a
most dangerous deception this theory
surely tends not only to mislead but to
debase men darkness is its element
sensuality it's fear the result of
accepting it is separation from God and
two fallen human nature
this means ruin living temple contains
the Alpha of these theories the Omega
would follow in a little while and I
tremble for our people she said what was
revealed to her in living temple what
Kellogg was writing about was the Alpha
the beginning it contained this idea
that God was in everything and she said
this was dangerous enough
she said what would come in the end was
even more dangerous she said I tremble
for our people the deception is gonna be
that great I want to show you a little
bit of how that's about to happen how
it's happening now
Satan has long been preparing for his
final effort to deceive the world the
foundation of his work was laid by the
assurance given to Eve in Eden you shall
not surely die for in the day you eat
thereof your eyes shall be opened and ye
shall be as gods give me another word
for your eyes shall be opened
enlightened enlightenment that phrase
enlightenment you can find in all the
occult societies all the Eastern
mystical religions and and philosophies
to enlighten someone he says for the day
ye eat thereof your eyes shall be opened
and ye shall be as God's knowing both
good and evil I used to think Satan was
telling Adam and Eve you're gonna be
gods literally and that was as far as it
went and it hit me how much more like
God can you be than Adam and Eve were
what was it like the day that Adam first
opened his eyes after Christ had had
formed him with his own hands out of the
dirt and the clay and then Christ did
mouth-to-mouth if you want with you to
look at it that way he breathed into
Adam the breath of life and Adam opened
as a HEIs what did what did Jesus say to
him do you know what Luke says when it
speaks about the lineage of Jesus it
traces it from Jesus all the way back in
Luke through Mary's lineage ah
all the way back from Jesus to Adam the
last statement it says is an Adam was
the Son of God
Adam and this is my sanctified thoughts
okay these are my thoughts
Adam opened his eyes and he's like what
do you do when you wake up because he
woke up as a full-grown mature man not
as an infant like we do right what what
thoughts were going through his mind can
you imagine that
and there's Jesus and he said you're my
son
I created you
I'm your elder brother you are a son of
God by creation how much more like God
could you be but Satan said something if
you eat of this fruit if you taste of
what I'm telling you and you try it you
can't just look at the food you've got
to taste it if you'll try what I'm
telling you to do you will be as gods
and then he said knowing both good and
evil the word knowing means discerning
for yourself and I went back in our red
patriarchs and prophets chapter one and
do you know what Satan said he said I
don't need God's divine influence I
don't need you whispering in my ear
what's right and wrong
you made me holy I can no more sin than
you can sin let go of my hand daddy I
can do it for myself that's what Satan
said I can decide for myself what's
right and wrong I don't need you telling
me what's right and wrong that's the
same thing he told the children of
Israel you don't need God's law to tell
you what's right and wrong
you can decide for yourself yeah I mean
y'all are grownups you can make your own
mind up he's telling the world the same
thing little by little
Satan has prepared the way for his
masterpiece of deception in the
development of spiritualism his
masterpiece of deception the greatest
deception that mankind is ever going to
face he has not yet reached the full
accomplishment of his designs but it
will be reached in the last remnant of
time that's where we're going with this
you want to know what's at the end of
the story that's where this is going
that's what we're gonna go in these
messages we're gonna show not only what
Satan is going to do through this last
great deception but we're going to show
what God is going to do among his people
amen
the period of Christ's personal ministry
among men was the time of greatest
activity for the forces of the kingdom
of darkness new life and love and power
from heaven were moving upon the hearts
of men now I want you to think about
this for a moment in Proverbs God tells
us my son my daughter give me your heart
he doesn't say just give me your mind
your intellect yes he wants the
intellect but he says give me your heart
that means your affections your loyalty
I want this this is the throne and the
Prince of evil was aroused to contend
for the supremacy of his kingdom
Satan summoned all his forces and at
every step he contested the work of
Christ
Ellen White says he was instilling
within men doubt doubt so it will be in
the great final conflict of the
controversy between righteousness and
sin while new life and light and power
are descending from on eye upon the
disciples of Christ a new life is
springing up from beneath energizing the
agencies of Satan intensity is taking
possession that's not just a she didn't
use these words just because they were
good words there's a meaning their
intensity is taking possession of every
earthly element with a subtlety gained
through the centuries of conflict the
Prince of evil works under a disguise he
appears clothed as an angel of light and
multitudes are giving heed to seducing
spirits and the doctrines and teachings
of devils now I want to look at a quote
and I know most of you are familiar with
this when Protestantism shall stretch
her hand across the gulf to grasp the
hand of the Roman power when she shall
reach over the abyss to clasp hands with
spiritualism when under the influence of
this threefold Union our country shall
make provision for the propagation or
spread of papal falsehoods and delusions
then we may know that the time has come
for the marvelous working of Satan and
that the end is near growing up as a
seventh-day adventists I can see the
Protestant churches of America clasping
hands with Rome our own church has done
that for years I mean you can you can
see
it you see leaders in our church going
and shaking hands with the UN director
and shaking hands with the Pope and
shaking hands with you know different
papal leaders so I could see a shaking
hey that's literal but I thought
spiritualism my mind says spiritualism
is the state of the dead right that's
how I grew up being taught spiritualism
is grandma really died she's really dead
the dead know not anything that's
spiritualism and I thought how do we
shake hands with spiritualism because
even in the churches that are in
apostasy I haven't yet seen a
seventh-day Adventist Church that's
teaching that when grandpa or grandma
die they go straight to heaven or hell I
haven't seen that yet I've seen some
really bad stuff but I haven't seen that
one how do we shake hands with
spiritualism it hit me
here we see modern Protestantism
evangelicals shaking hands with Rome
here we see Rome shaking hands with
spiritualism the dragon and revelation
yes it represents Satan but on a
physical level it also is the symbol of
Eastern mysticism if you go to a Chinese
restaurant I guarantee you're gonna see
a dragon over the doorway somewhere in
the house do you know why because when
they put that over the doorway it's like
it being put upon your head your
forehead they're saying this is who
empowers and blesses this business if
you go into any martial arts school
you're gonna see a dragon almost
guaranteed either a painting or a
picture or on a t-shirt or on a uniform
because that is the highest power known
in the martial arts world
the dragon in Chinese ki Gong and
Chinese buck wah in Tai Chi the dragon
is known as the the spirit power the
greatest spiritual power so how do you
get if we if I was Rome if I was the
symbol for Rome and I get all of those
Protestants to come on board with me
except for that little remnant of people
that are keeping the Sabbath okay so
fine you got the Christians what about
the Buddhists and the Hindus they
outnumber the Christians unbelievably
how do you get them to come to Rome I
mean they could care less about the Pope
right how do you get them there what
about the Muslim world how are you gonna
get all those Muslims back to Rome well
that's a little easier than the
Buddhists and Hindus you have to find
common ground spiritualism saying that
God is in everything is common ground
with the Buddhists and the Hindus and
the Taoist and the Shinto religion it's
common ground
Rome is joining the world together
revelation 16 says I saw three unclean
spirits like frogs what is the common
thing that you think about with a frog
if you ask a little child show me what a
frog does or what they look like what's
the child gonna do they stick their
tongue out that's that's like common
they are they hop and they stick the
tongue out the tongue is tongues when
you say you speak in tongues we know
that is words languages right I saw
three unclean spirits like frogs tongues
languages words jesus said the words I
speak unto you they are spirit and they
are life when the devil speak
words there are spirits that are
inspiring those words these spirits came
out of the mouth of dragon out of the
mouth of the dragon spiritualism out of
the mouth of the beast Roman Catholicism
and out of the mouth of the false
prophet apostate Protestantism these
three powers are all speaking under the
inspiration of Satan and his fallen
angels for they are the spirits of
Devil's working miracles which go forth
unto the kings of the earth and the
whole world to gather them to the Battle
of the great day of El Shaddai God
Almighty he's gathering them together to
make war with him that sits upon the
horse spiritism it means the study of
communication with spirit entities and
we talked about this in our last session
it was introduced into the Christian
West by a man named Allan Kardec
who lived from 1804 to 1869
spiritualism which Ellen White uses
these two phrases interchangeably many
times the practice of communicating with
the dead usually through the use of a
medium or Channel now I want to
interject something just some food for
thought because we can't pass over these
things lightly when my wife and I first
got married we were on fire for sharing
the gospel for helping people to know
Christ is coming so we would you know we
would meet somebody and invite them over
for Bible study or ask if we could come
over and and they'd say oh I would love
that you know I'm a Christian too and so
we set up a time we could have dinner or
whatever and my wife and I would go home
and we would pull out our list okay what
Bible studies do we do okay here's one
two three four five here's ten of the
things they don't know about well within
those top five it's always the state of
the Dead right that's common you you hit
people with that what I have realized
over the last few years is if that
person is struggling with sin in their
life what difference does it make now
where grandma is at I'm not saying that
it's not important but this person's got
a bigger issue this woman her husband
just left her and their children and I
come and I'm gonna give her a Bible
study on the state of the Dead and she's
thinking my husband's gone I need I need
help with that I'm not saying that the
the truth is not important you
understand but there's a greater truth
Ellen White said that every doctrine we
have Christ should be the center of it
and I was like so how do you do that and
then I read some sermons by WW Prescott
that he gave in Australia in 1895 can it
change my life Ellen White was there he
spoke more than 30 times at that one
camp-meeting more than 30 messages and
she said I have never seen the Spirit of
God upon a man like this since 1888 and
do you know what he did he presented
every truth and doctrine we have without
ever telling you he was teaching a
doctrine he presented Christ and I'll
give you an example stated the dead if I
tell someone you were crucified with
Christ and they say yeah but I wasn't
even alive yeah but you were in him you
were crucified with Christ you were
buried by baptism with Christ you are
risen to newness of life in Christ and
they say well yeah but I've got this sin
problem that I can't get rid of and you
go well the Bible says if any man or
woman is in Christ they are a new
creation old things are passed away
that's dead grandma passed away grandpa
passed away rest in peace and the dead
know not anything that means if I'm
still talking to the old man the one
that had left his wife and children and
and done all the terrible things I did
if I'm still communicating with him that
spiritualism because he died with Christ
Paul says forgetting those things that
are behind we are to press forward we
have to reckon ourselves to be dead
indeed unto sin but alive unto God
through Christ Jesus when you share that
with someone who's struggling then all
of a sudden they're excited and they go
man I never thought about that I did die
with Jesus the Bible says yeah but I
don't feel dead doesn't matter how you
feel believe it and
walk in newness of life because God's
called you to do so and then you can go
oh yeah by the way if you're worried
about what happened to your son or
daughter you know look this is what the
Bible says then it becomes important to
them as we near the close of time there
will be greater and still greater
external parade of heathen power
external that means you're going to see
it of heathen power heathen deities
pagan gods will manifest their signal
power and will exhibit themselves before
the cities of the world when I first
heard someone preach on this and I
thought that can't but LOI didn't say
that
and I had to go look it up and then I
was like oh wow it's there and I was
like so there's actually we're gonna see
demonic spirits physically manifest and
then I read a little bit farther and
this delineation what she just described
has already begun to be fulfilled and I
thought how are people where where are
these demons manifesting themselves
physically where we can see them with
our eyes and then she says I'll need
wisdom carefully to search out the
mystery of iniquity that figures so
largely in the winding up of this
Earth's history there are two mysteries
spoken of in Scripture two mysteries I
should say there may be more but there's
two that are prominently brought before
us the first one is the mystery of
godliness talks about that in first
Timothy 3:16 the mystery of godliness is
that God was manifest in human flesh
the next mystery Paul talks about and
warns
called the mystery of iniquity so if the
mystery of godliness is God manifests in
human flesh the mystery of iniquity
could it be
Satan manifest in human flesh this began
to make sense to me there's something
else I want to share here but I'm gonna
save that let me show you what we have
found Paul says let no man deceive you
by any means for that day of Christ's
return shall not come except there come
a falling away an apostasy first and
that man of sin be revealed that word in
greek means unmasked or unveiled
do you remember Christ veiled his deity
with humanity he put us on right does
the Bible not say that we are to put ye
on the Lord Jesus Christ so just like
Christ stepped into a human flesh and
bone he tells us put me on and don't
make provision for your flesh to fulfill
the lusts thereof that means don't buy
an insurance policy in case of failure
don't make provision for the flesh
well what if we fail that's what
happened at Mount Sinai God said these
are promises I promise every command is
a promise Ellen White said that in
education beige 126 and I remember
reading that I thought how can the
commandments be promises God said read
it out loud with your name in it don't
read it for somebody else this is
written to you personally make the Bible
a letter that God has written to
you and I was like I still don't
understand God said read it out loud I
said okay I'll give you an example the
one I fell at the most thou shalt not
commit adultery God was like now read it
again with your name in it I was like
Dow Dow okay all right Eric William
Wilson I promise you won't commit
adultery and I was like oh wow that
changes everything I used to hear this
as a young man growing up they'll not
commit adultery or else imma I will kill
you that's how I saw God that's how God
wants people to see him God said I
promise if you will surrender and let my
son come and live inside you and if you
will abide in him I promise you won't
commit adultery even in your heart let
this mind be in you which was in Christ
Jesus
he never consented to sin even in his
thoughts all of a sudden it began to
make sense Christ said don't make
provision for failure don't buy an
insurance policy well what if I fail God
there is no what if Ellen White said
Christ's life demonstrates to us that
humanity United to deity does not commit
sin you can read that in 1st John
chapter 3 9 look it up in Ellen White's
writings that's a powerful promise we've
got to be united to him and that man of
sin will be unveiled as the son of
perdition who opposeth and exalteth
himself above all that is called God or
that is worshipped so that he as God
sitteth in the temple of God showing
himself that he
is God I want to show you something and
I want you to make a note of this I want
you to go home tonight or tomorrow and
read desire of Ages page 162 161 desire
of Ages page 162 161 Paul tells us in
first and second Corinthians know ye not
that you are the temple of God and that
the Spirit of God dwells in you right he
as God sitteth in the temple of God I'm
not denying that one day we may see
something over in the Middle East I'm
not denying that it's very likely that
that we could see Rome possibly move you
know their their headquarters there but
let me tell you something that's not
near as important as knowing that Satan
wants to take the throne of your heart
personally know ye not that ye are the
temple of God and that the Spirit of God
dwelleth in you If any man defiles the
temple of God him shall God destroy for
the temple of God is holy which temple
we are I used to think God's gonna be so
angry at me if I mess up he's gonna kill
me God said I want to come and live
inside of you and I am a consuming fire
I'm a consuming fire if you keep
bringing those things into my temple I'm
here and I'm a consuming fire I don't
want to burn you does that make sense
when we come back tomorrow evening we're
gonna really really open this up I can't
wait til tomorrow evening so I look
forward to seeing you all then
[Music]